[Music]
satan
the beast crunching sinner's bones in
his subterranean lair
lucifer the fallen angel raging against
the established order
mephistopheles the trickster striking
deals with
unsuspecting humans these three
divergent devils
are all based on satan of the old
testament
an angelic member of god's court who
torments
job in the book of job but unlike
any of these literary devils the satan
of the bible
was a relatively minor character with
scant information about his deeds or
appearance so how did he become the
ultimate antagonist with so many
different forms
in the new testament satan saw a little
more action
tempting jesus using demons to possess
people
and finally appearing as a giant dragon
who is cast into hell this last image
particularly inspired medieval artists
and writers
who depicted a scaled shaggy furred
creature
with overgrown toenails in michael
parker's painting of saint augustine and
the devil
the devil appears as an upright lizard
with a second miniature face glinting on
his rear end
the epitome of these monster satans
appeared in italian poet
dante alighieri's inferno
encased in the ninth circle of hell
dante's satan is a three-headed
batwinged behemoth who feasts on sinners
but he's also an object of pity
powerless as the panicked beating of his
wings
only encases him further in ice
the poem's protagonist escapes from hell
by clambering
over satan's body and feels both disgust
and sympathy for the trapped beast
prompting the reader to consider the
pain of doing evil
by the renaissance the devil started to
assume a more human form
artists painted him as a man with cloven
hooves
and curling horns inspired by pan the
greek god of the wild
in his 1667 masterpiece paradise lost
english poet john milton depicted the
devil
as lucifer an angel who started a
rebellion
on the grounds that god is too powerful
kicked out of heaven this charismatic
rebel
becomes satan and declares that he'd
rather rule in hell
than serve in heaven milton's take
inspired
numerous depictions of lucifer as an
ambiguous figure
rather than a purely evil one milton's
lucifer later became an iconic character
for the romantics of the 1800s who saw
him as a hero
who defied higher power in pursuit of
essential truths
with tragic consequences
meanwhile in the german legend of dr
faust
which dates to the 16th century we get a
look at what happens when the devil
comes to earth
faust a dissatisfied scholar pledges his
soul to the devil
in exchange for bottomless pleasure with
the help of the devil's messenger
mephistopheles faust quickly seizes
women
power and money only to fall into the
eternal fires
of hell later versions of the story
show mephistopheles in different lights
in christopher marlowe's account a
cynical dr faustus
is happy to strike a deal with
mephistopheles
in johann wolfgang van gerter's version
mephistopheles tricks
faust into a grizzly deal today
a faustian bargain refers to a trade
that sacrifices
integrity for short-term gains
in stagings of goethe's play
mephistopheles appeared in red tights
and cape
this version of the devil was often
played as a charming
trickster one that eventually paraded
through comic books
advertising and film in his red suit
these three takes on the devil are just
the tip
of the iceberg the devil continues to
stalk the public imagination to this day
tempting artists of all kinds to render
him
according to new and fantastical visions
what happens when the devil walks among
us follow the entwined stories of a
famed architect and a ruthless
serial killer at the 1893 world fair
with eric larson's
the devil in the white city dive into a
world of murder
magic and madness by downloading a free
audiobook on audible.com
ted ed